[Music]
and just a prank bro News great so if
made it by AO Netflix is defending a new
show that received instant backlash oh
good job I love Netflix though but do
you really which one
what do you think it is yeah we think is
a new show yeah is it when they see us I
thought black mayor
oh no oh wait is it the is it the one
what about the black boys that's the one
I see no just kidding they call that
when they say yeah you're right it is it
is so this new show it stars the kid
from stranger things which one his name
is getting the two full name is Dustin
on the show so he is hosting and being
an executive producer on the one doll
called the scene 16 okay he looks 12
[ __ ] with my life I know right I feel
when I watch these kids I mean we're
here filming just kidding is I know my
[ __ ] potatoes yes so this new show
it's called prank encounters it says
quote each episode of this terrifying
and hilarious prank show takes two
complete strangers who each think
they're starting their first day at a
new job it's business as usual until
their pets collide and these part-time
jobs turn into full-time nightmares that
sounds fun so people were really upset
because they're singing on Twitter of
course
hey Gatton this isn't a group of people
to be pulling pranks on please
reconsider this one punch up not down
and then someone else said great
something else for the unemployed to
worry about oh damn I don't even think
like people are so good at thinking like
so far ahead we might just that
self-centered that I would never be like
oh great now the unemployed
no I think that people look for what can
I get triggered by okay that's not very
[ __ ] they want to feel important and
opinionated and like they're so gonna
stand on Superman and
to save people never you can literally
take any sentence cause anything show
ideas drink water though why are you
shaming people that don't don't like the
taste of water and other people and
don't have water yeah this is like I
don't want to show my privilege that I
can drink clean water and they don't get
oh my god fasting Wow you get triggered
pretty [ __ ] my head hurts on the
internet just like going off on people
picture that cat thank you but yet
another tweet says is your next project
going to be about pranking people who
think it cure has been found for a
terminal oh god so many people involved
in this show who should have known how
cool this idea was people are [ __ ]
ridiculous both for your career you're
so bored out there do they not realize
that if it's on a show like these people
are probably actors right yeah or they
got some sort of like release form and
they after the fact we got paid yeah
they pay them do you guys remember when
like before the internet was so
accessible to everybody like famous
people would be like oh I don't really
read comments I don't really get
involved yeah now I get it because like
imagine being that kid and reading the
comments on your news show you'd
probably be like [ __ ] I don't even take
care of that stuff like that's not even
my real job you know like I just stand
there and then do the thing here the
exact people are bored and they need to
take themselves too seriously to feel
like they have some purpose instead of
finding a real purpose they go and latch
on to try to feel some sense of purpose
but it never is fulfilling because it's
not really real yeah and so they just
keep latching on to different things to
get offended about and just go find an
identity built an identity and then
you'll be fine like you'll just [ __ ]
calm down yeah yeah so Netflix came out
and said like hold on calm down
everybody
let me clarify some [ __ ] and they said
quote the pranks and prank encounters
are spooky supernatural and over-the-top
and everyone had a great time all
participants came in with the
expectation that this was a one-day
hourly gig and everyone got paid for
their time
right like that was obvious maybe these
people believe that like they believe
prank shows or they just believe that
like shows like it just happens on the
fly and nobody agreed to like they got
you outside right now Wow and even on
the radio you know how they would always
do those prank calls like in the morning
or whatever I love it for your morning
drive like all those are fake like every
client's roses ass man yeah reason is
sometimes the host plays the caller too
like they they go back and forth you
have to have it released to put your
voice on the radio or like your personal
life or not sparking wag why are you
guys what are you on the Internet what
about the one where it's like the friend
is breaking the mom or some [ __ ] what do
you mean so like me I'm the friend
I'm calling the radio station but hey
those are all fake jets just crushed
everyone's heart right now yeah that's
why I need to know and you stopped doing
pranks because they wanted him to do it
to fake his pranks because all of his
are real and then he stopped doing it
because the top rankers they all faked
their pranks and she hated that so
that's why he stopped doing it yeah and
also do monetization because like you
prank you recently no he could never
prank me oh there's no way I can spy his
lying like a million miles away he was
gonna try to do pull up a fake proposal
and even when he was trying to talk in
code do like the person he was doing
elephone like you're really gonna fake
proposed to me I will leave you right
now and then he's like no okay they
suggested it and like they it was in the
talks but I would have told you and I'm
like mom [ __ ] like the prank was
gonna be he proposes with a promise ring
Wow yeah and be like I promised it was
for pro good prank and I was like why
didn't he do that on his channel cuz I
remember seeing that around the time you
guys got engaged it wasn't real it was a
sketch thing right I remember that one
but he and he wasn't a restaurant yeah
the Denny's 100k so that wasn't like a
pranking me yeah that was oh like we did
a satire on all the guys that do
proposal videos where they make it about
them yeah and then it like goes viral
and all the girls are like fully good so
sweet but really like the guy just wants
to get a bunch of praise yeah
I chose her because she does did it and
he takes all these pictures and the
whole videos about him but it's about
how like sweet he is yeah so he did a
like satire about those guys that do
that but people thought that was his
real proposal because they thought I was
legit pissed you're a really good actor
but I was like wearing my wedding ring
ever my engagement ring in the video
because I forgot to take it off but the
acting was great
oh nice so people more tweets they're
saying getting you seem like a cool kid
but please don't
as someone who is currently unemployed
this just comes across as unnecessary it
always is like that it's their identity
that's someone who is currently
unemployed like like there's so many
things online earning you could do like
post mates like I don't know ever
there's a lot of things that you can do
Paul said hey Netflix great job I
struggle to find work for a year and it
drove me to the brink but didn't they
explain that it was for one day an
hourly pay yeah I mean they're explained
after the fact that thing I'll bother
they kind of had to ruin it though like
yeah like when you watch the show like
you kind of want to think like they
actually think they're coming in for
work but then now they had to like ruin
it
imagine if Jack us what it came out like
in this Danny Trejo copy but would have
died thank the internet would have like
heated up absolutely not
it was so like there were so many wrong
things especially like they used that
little the little person like really
disrespectfully like those people like
and they have to know about it right
yeah they just what do they say like oh
it already happened there's nothing they
say like oh that was a different era
it's a lot of younger people that get
heated in it's like they were even
around enough to comment back then they
just understand the culture that we
lived in on evil era back then yeah
because then they'll be pulling up old
episodes of like friends or yeah yeah
wheeler TV shows and our Netflix now and
then they'll pull up these episodes back
oh my god I can't believe they said that
but it's like dude that was the culture
back then someone was trying to claim
Gwen Stefani as cultural appropriation
for I think India and that all kind of
well she does kind of use a lot of other
cultures uh but it's not like it was
never done in a disrespectful way well
she never tried to claim it such a line
on the cultural appropriation day and
that I using it from I can't I don't but
I don't understand yeah because I don't
Tunis like some things that I look just
like you were inspired by that like I
don't think should be counted as a
cultural appropriation coffee yeah I
think is when it's [ __ ] up any when
it's for monetary purposes like it when
the yeah got the the indigenous Mexicans
making what up cheese and then now it's
like a factory like I do target right
right right and that's kind of like I
think the thing is like what gwen
stefani for example and this was a
different time but if it was to happen
to like a white girl was doing all the
Asian things and trying to like sell a
people would be like why don't we get an
Asian girl to be less popular as when
tray you know but I mean it's kind of
crazy to think about other people a
couple of people told me to like talk
about it but I really didn't want to but
did you guys see YG's new album so the
gore loca one and like he's like in full
mariachi suit like full mariachi and
like people are like oh that's a black
guy in mariachi I was like [ __ ] I'm not
getting involved like I don't want to
take a stand because it's really
confusing to talk about you know like
it's really completing to take a stand
and then people want you to be the face
of it and you to defend it yeah you want
you to use your influence yeah but Henry
got their opinion
yeah like imagine me going against yg I
feel like uh yeah I mean yeah I guess
where the suit like I don't know what to
tell you is you're confused and how you
feel about it I mean I personally don't
care but I also don't represent all of
Mexico right I don't represent all of
Mexican Americans you know so I could
only steep my opinion and then I'm just
one person on the internet you know and
like truly if I was to sit with yg and
he was like oh what do you think can I
wear this I'd be like well I mean did
you like do you know the history of
Minea cheese like you know what I mean
like do you know where it comes from do
you know why they wear those suits how
much work it takes to be in one yet like
all that stuff so like what does it have
to do with the art that you're creating
alright did you just slap this on like
because it looks cool or like it has
like some sort of cloud like if you
listen to this song like they go loco
song like he says like hella [ __ ] like
in hella like you know how hip-hop has
like hella bad words yeah like in
Spanish it always sounds weird to me
like I don't like to hear them in
Spanish and English I don't really care
you know but like you know he says like
butta in his songs
I was like what you don't really say
that you know but you know like it's
crazy to think about how people can
someone can monetize off of it but but
because he's also a minority like people
haven't really made it a big deal you
know if he was a white guy doing it I'd
be away it would be a boy bigger dude
but I don't feel like he did it in like
satire type of way I feel like he just
like Gwen Stefani was inspired by Asian
people and like they did it with like
yeah because he's using Spanish in his
song yeah it's tightened throught
Spanish like artists into the song too
yeah you know yeah so I don't think I
have bad intentions yeah and that's a
fine line that Nicki was saying like
what's the line between appreciating and
like showing the culture and like
totally completely stealing off of it
you know cuz there's hella Mexican
rappers who are not as big as yg yeah so
why not give them that spotlight you
know so I don't I'm not taking a stand
right now and I'm not saying where I
stand but it's just confusing to think
about even like where I have to say to
be like man how do I feel about this you
know it makes my brain hurt yeah I'm
going to honestly I just know just I'm
white I can't do [ __ ] just don't do [ __ ]
besides my white [ __ ] and I'll be good
and I'm did you get any flack for
dressing up in kimonos a couple people
are like oh wait til the internet sees
this and I'm like boyfriend is Japanese
and his mom asked me to put it on so at
that point you can't really say anything
else it's like like the one article that
it you can't please everyone yeah well
better looking to get triggered will
just get triggered it doesn't they're
just looking to be offended that is
their whole identity is getting a thin
yeah and Japanese like those stores are
set up for tourists so it's like how
could you be mad at that like they want
you to come in and take the pictures
with it and they are paying then hey
them in the culture yeah and that's kind
of crazy to think about because like
Mexican Americans I can only speak for
us we get more offended than people in
Mexico like people in Mexico don't get
three [ __ ] literally yeah you know and
here like it's almost that we're trying
to hold on to that culture so much that
we're like why are you wearing it why
are you doing it yeah it's true it's
like those videos where like Chinese
people try Chinese American Chinese food
and like pin Express and stuff and the
younger Chinese people are like oh this
is nice this is not Chinese people
and the older Chinese people that came
from China their life was good
[Music]